hello everyone and welcome to game
number 21 of the 1960 World Chess
Championship match between Michael tal
and the Mikhail Botvinnik now as you've
seen in the previous game botanique did
did have some opportunities to continue
the game but he decided to accept the
draw offer and decided to go into game
21 and here before the game started the
result is 12 to 18 12 a versatile is
still four points in the lead and the
old tile needs the windows win this
entire match is to draw this game and if
what we need you know if botanique was
to actually continue the struggle he
would have to win four games in a row at
the tightest score to be 1212
and thought wasn't sure if you know if
what Nick was gonna do this if botanique
had given up on the match or was he
really going to try and win four
consecutive games in a row that's what's
not a quote about the board but it's
it's one sentence from Todd's book it
was hard to convince myself that
Botvinnik would play for a win in each
of the four remaining games so yeah that
basically what that means and yeah also
didn't know if botanique maybe and maybe
drew the previous game maybe too early
to maybe get inside of Todd's head so
Todd would think is bought in he had
given up on the match so a lot of things
to consider here everyone was already
congratulating tall and saying eh I mean
you just have to draw one more game out
of the four games but total he still had
to play a nice game so as this is the
final game
let's see some photos here we have a
nice photo of the Pushkin theater in
Moscow there are tau and botanique
playing there you have to show Bohr a
show boards one on the left and one on
the right and the audience is right here
but I also have one photo from the other
side so you can see that there are
actually multiple multiple not layers of
audience but multiple like stairs
yeah not stairs I don't know the word
I'm looking for damn but it doesn't
really matter here is a nice close-up
this is maybe from the last round maybe
not
I don't really know it's hard the same
and all of these
all of these photos are from from a
short clip and the link to that clip
will be in the description below so feel
free to check it out it's on uh it's
some on some British channel I don't
know if they have like like the the rice
to showed this footage but it's there
and no one no one's doing anything about
it so so feel free to check it out I
guess and I do have some more but we'll
leave those for after the game so let's
see it
d4 so this has to go d4 in this game he
tried to find he tried to find an
opening and the line in this opening
that allows both me to go for a quiet
opening but also if boating decides to
go for a sharp landed it can immediately
be seen and dealt with so for the first
time in this matched all opens with the
d4 and we have Knight to f6 c4 e6 and
here
Todd didn't want to play Knight to c3 he
wanted to see what Botvinnik would if
both would go for the Queen's Indian or
not for the Queen's Indian for the
nimzo-indian defense and how he would
handle Tao semi attack but he didn't in
any other game he would have done this
but not in this one he did hear him play
Knight to f3 and botany responded with
b6 so the quiet Queen's Indian defense
and thought was actually very happy to
see this so g3 continuing in a similar
similar fashion gonna counter botanics
b7 bishop or the g2 bishop so Bishop to
b7 Bishop to g2 and now Bishop to e7
dark castles botany castles nice to see
three and now Knight to e4 Queen c2 with
a double attack on the night Knight
captures Queen captures and f5 and this
was a well-known theoretical position at
the time and here top plate b3 if he
really wanted to go for an for an edged
again and any kind of an advantage and
if he was playing any other game but
this one he would have gone for d5 which
would which would promise out a
complicated and sharp game but here he
prefers a calm continuation he plays b3
preparing to develop the Bishop Bishop
to f6 now comes Bishop to b2 and now d6
rook a to d1 Queen to e7 and now nice to
e1 we have Bishop captures an G - so
tallow for the trade of Bishops and of
course botnik there really isn't a
better move than simply accepting the
bishop
we have Knight captures and now Knight
to c6 Queen to f3 attacking the knight
on c6 and Queen to d7 defending it
Knight to f4 now tau is threatening
Knight captures on e6 of course if Queen
captures then Queen captures and c6 is a
threat so rook 88 defending the d6 pawn
and here tau did think about this
position for a while and he decided that
it was a perfectly safe position for him
and if he didn't really know what to
play III that's definitely a move but
what is e 3 doing I mean probably
nothing so he decided to play d5 with
with the following idea he wanted to
Bishop capture some b2 and he kept D
captures on e6 would an attack on the
Queen and now of course if you move the
Queen then Queen captures and c6 you win
back the piece but the real idea is nice
to e5 attacking task Queen so after pawn
captures Knight captures with chick
we have pawn captures and now rook to e7
here Todd's idea was before so after
black recaptures at the pawn on g7 to
play b5 and now this B phone would be
preventing this a point from coming
forward and also keeping this week's e7
pawn at bay so this was kind of tossed
idea when he pushed to d5 and this is
what he expected he didn't really find
any any other other good moves for black
but Botnick botanique played the
absolute strongest move and he played a
move that tall definitely didn't expect
the move is Knights to d8 but the reason
thought didn't expected is because here
after night to d8 on move 17 Botvinnik
actually offered tau a draw so Botvinnik
in fact had given up on the championship
and he decided there was really no way
to try and win for concern for
consecutive games in a row so Knight to
the 8th move 17 a draw offer and Tull
happily accepted this offer so by this
move and here even I
prepare some nice last words by tal
himself from his book but unfortunately
these are tells last words from the book
as you can see in 96 to d8 so this is
the move and it says well made me a
flattering offer so it says baa tunic
prior to this made me a flattering offer
botnik 17th move was destined to be the
last move in this match and this is the
last sentence in the book I thought
there will be something like after that
you know talking about something but the
religions maybe maybe in a Russian
version maybe this is just a bad
translation who knows if anyone read the
Russian version you know maybe there
really is something that we could add
here but yeah that's basically it and so
out of 21 games the tall one the match
with twelve and a half to eight and a
half so with a four point lead that's I
mean that's that's a very nice result to
win the World Chess Championship and
here we do have a couple of more photos
here is the crowd from the other angle
so you can see down there and also also
there are some people upstairs all of
them are applauding town now for winning
the World Chess Championship title and
here we have tall ready to receive his
prize and also here another photo of him
receiving it and being being
congratulated officially so there aren't
there aren't that many photos or video
footage of this event but there are some
on the internet so feel free to look for
them like I said I will put a link with
a short clip about you know it's a very
short clip in Russian where they show
tall and botnik and now winning the
championship so feel free to check it
out and yeah feel free to check out all
of the games from this world chess
championship all 21 of them and once
again I will invite you to check out my
coverage of the 1959 candidates
tournament the tournament still had to
win I had to actually get this
opportunity to face me called Botvinnik
and now at the end of this video I
realized that I left the photos yeah I
actually left the photos towel is towel
is up there and both me is down there
but okay I will edit
this out maybe yeah uh as this is the
last video I will edit this and then
upload it so totally completely
disregard this last sentence I said so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I do hope you enjoyed my
entire coverage of this match so now we
have all of the 21 games you know you're
free to do whatever you want with them
you can download them you can burn them
to a CD well not a CD it won't fit on a
CD but may maybe on a blu-ray it will
end you know mmm you can give it to a
grandpa so he can also check it out you
know it'd be nice for him to remember
the good old days so I would like to
thank at the naseous Marcus and Richard
Lewis for a contribution to my channel
thanks a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon
probably with one of your suggestions as
it's been a while since I did any of our
suggestions I was too busy with the
candidates name with a cranky jazz
classic and then with covering this
match so for for for for for some time
now I will be mostly doing suggestions
and some you know isolated incidents in
the chess world and then probably I will
return to some other series you know
there are a lot of great World Chess
Championships that were played and there
are a lot of great candidates
tournaments that were played and
tournaments in general so yeah once
again thank you for you know enjoying
and increasing your vast knowledge of
the 1960 World Chess Championship match
between Michael and Michael Botwin
thank you all and I will see you soon